on sunday relative calm returned to sri
lanka protesters remained at the
president's official residence making
use of facilities normally reserved for
the country's elites
sri lanka's 22 million people have for
months been suffering the worst economic
crisis the country has seen since
independence from the british in 1948
the summer heat compounding electricity
blackouts fuel food and medicine
shortages and years of paralyzing
political corruption
the greatest thing the people and the
youth of this country has ever done is
to chase this man away he was expelled
chased away he did not resign he doesn't
have the sovereignty of the people now
what we need to do is very simple the
people who love this country must unite
to rebuild it
as protests swelled president gotabaya
rajapaksa fled his overrun residence and
left the mainland to the safety of an
offshore naval ship
he is no longer the president of sri
lanka he has been expelled by the
citizens of sri lanka therefore this is
a victorious moment
official resignations from leaders for a
nation in rebellion now little more than
formalities this is going to be an
extremely critical time to ensure
there's political stability
as well as economic stability at a time
where there's also a law and order
situation erupting so if violence is not
contained there is concern that this is
going to deepen the crisis so very very
important times ahead for sri lanka
overseas remittances and tourism are the
country's main sources of revenue
after isil bomb attacks on churches and
hotels in 2019
and then the kovid 19 pandemic both
dried up
the united nations has warned with
millions already in need of basic help a
humanitarian crisis is looming
the latest political turmoil
has been a long time coming
zayn basravi al jazeera